[Music]
this is star talk cosmic queries edition
and today we're going to dip into
chemistry
chuck are you with me here chuck i am i
am yeah yeah how do you feel about
chemistry chuck
i am i'm waiting for you to dip into it
that's it
okay that's i have to say that i had a
terrible chemistry teacher
and
ruined the entire experience for me
you're the walking wounded okay i am the
walking
wounded of chemistry and i um i won't
say his name but i remember him
vividly and um he would explain
something
and
then
immediately expect us to know
like what the next thing is
and
you know he would do this and everyone
would sit in the classroom kind of like
in this terrified state because it's
terrible to feel like completely
ignorant and it's worse to feel stupid
because stup ignorant is one thing but
you feel stupid when somebody has an
expectation of you that you're not
meeting
chuck are you still in therapy for this
yeah this sounds
sounds like you got a lot to shake right
so then wait a minute then you know me i
i'm sorry i asked okay i say no i say
what's on my mind so he didn't like me
because
he asked a question
and we hadn't covered it right
and so i said to him in front of the
whole class
you do realize you have a degree in
chemistry
this is high school
and then he said what are you a comedian
and the rest is history
well uh neither you nor i carry
any kind of significant chemistry
expertise so we went out into the ether
oh yeah and we found kate the chemist
kate the chemist welcome to star talk
thank you so much for having me i'm very
excited to be here yeah excellent uh you
were
i was trying to say the lady please no i
was just gonna say i can already tell
you're gonna make me like chemistry just
the name kate the chemist it's like hey
i'm like i need to hear more
so you are you're you're okay that's
what we call you on the internet but uh
behind you know park the curtains you
are uh professor kate bieberdorf and
you're on the faculty at the university
of texas at austin in their department
of chemistry so this is just way
excellent and you've written books
previously just for kids but recently
you have a book that came out a few
months ago for grown-ups
so that's cool i would have to get the
title here it's elemental the hidden
chemistry of everything i love the title
and so kate let me ask you is this
finally grown-ups get to
create a fire in the carpet in the
living room
yeah we have now that's exactly what it
is yeah
that's what the book is and i teach you
how to do fireworks right in the middle
of your living room that's
that's how that's everybody's memory of
the chemistry kit
growing up
but the kids do all the time
all the time the parents come up to me
after these shows because i blow stuff
up for kids and they keep asking me
these questions and they're like my
little kid has this question about
sunscreen i was like your five-year-old
has a question about sunscreen and
they're using their kids to ask the
questions so in the book i literally
just went through and answered all their
questions that they've ever asked me oh
i got you okay in fairness it could have
been a very vain five-year-old that's
true
that's true
i gotta keep this tight i have got to
keep this tight i know i'm five but i'm
thinking ahead
so what what is kate the chemist fiction
series what is that
um there are seven books so five fiction
ones and then there's two non-fiction
ones but the fiction series is this
little ten-year-old name kate the
chemist and she goes around her
neighborhood and
solves any problems in the neighborhood
using science um it was just so fun to
write because for the first time ever i
could like make stuff up like you can't
do that in the chemistry world you can't
lie about things and so here i could
just have little kids breathing fire and
it was just an absolute blast so what is
what is one scenario that might be
solved with chemistry in terms of like a
mystery or a problem in a book series
so the very first one is called dragons
versus unicorns and it's the little kid
very scientific
very scientific chuck she says she made
this stuff up and it is called fiction
okay
learn the definition of the word fiction
chuck okay well to be real honestly
that's kind of the reason why is they're
trying to get people who might be
intimidated by science like some kids
don't want to read a science book but
they might want to read dragons versus
unicorns and so it's a way to kind of
hook kids especially little girls and
get them excited about science and in
the series little k goes around and
she's kind of the director of the
musical and there's all these problems
like the unicorns horns fall off and so
she has to make glue using science to
get the stick so it'll stay on the
forehead so there's a lot of little ways
i can sneak it in there um and it's just
a blast i had so much fun right i
thought you would tell me what dragon
breath is made of see
yeah it is and so what she does is so in
the very beginning we have the little
girl breathe fire um it's just this big
experiment so it's really exciting but
they wouldn't let her do it in the
musical so it's a big deal um so they
end they end up using cheetos and liquid
nitrogen so you dip the cheetos into
liquid nitrogen give it a second and
then you can bite down in it when you
exhale you end up breathing it's gas
it's smoke right into the condensation
but yeah it's so they there's a little
bit of dragon breath in there okay so so
it's smoke dragon breath not flame
no
no the editor had a little bit of a
problem with that as a chemist if if if
dragons actually breathe fire like like
smog right so i mean as in the
desolation of smog as in the desolation
of smog so smog you see his um you see
his belly
actually
glow
red
and then the inside of his throat
becomes very hot and then
boom it becomes radiant and ready to
come out yes and then there's a plume of
fire
from a
from a chemist standpoint yeah kate
explain that what would be that fire i'm
serious how would you justify that
scientifically now come on we know we
got to suspend disbelief but if we could
justify that scientifically what would
be that fire
well i could tell you what fire is fire
is a combustion reaction and it's any
time you have a source of fuel you have
reacted with oxygen and then you form
carbon dioxide and water that's a
traditional one and so what you're
seeing is the release of that energy
exothermically being shot out i breathe
fire using cornstarch which is a lot
easier a lot safer but that doesn't
start in my belly i just put it in my
mouth and spit it out but you're saying
there's a safe way to breathe fire
that's why you just said that
i could okay
as opposed to the dangerous ways of
breathing fire i can do it safely
uh yeah okay how about this have i got
one i got one i got one okay so
uh as we all know
uh they're they're anaerobic microbes
deep in our gut and
they
release methane
normally the methane
comes out
the back end
but if you could somehow reverse that
tube and then have it come out of your
mouth and then ignite it then you could
breathe fire with methane a gas that you
produced yourself so there you have it
basically uh dragons have flatulent
mouths
[Laughter]
that was that was the joke so thank you
yeah normally i don't steep lower than
you go but
i'm always getting the letters
it's true it is true why are you always
trying to bring neil degrasse tyson down
that's so funny oh
all right so so you know this is
actually a cosmic queries edition
because you know we hardly ever have
chemists and i'm embarrassed by that
because chemistry is you know some of my
best friends are made of chemicals and
so we need more chemistry in this show
and kate for those who are seeing us on
video you are graced on your back wall
by of course a periodic table of
elements and but that looks a little
different from ones i'm familiar with
did you steal that from
your your where'd you get that from
etsy um i ordered it off etsy i found
one i was looking for something for my
back wall that wasn't too busy or crazy
and i just i don't i'm not very artistic
i don't like putting things up on my
walls and i stumbled upon this it's a
periodic table from 1963 so it's
organized a little bit differently you
don't have the lanthanides and actinides
at the bottom which people are
traditionally used to see of course not
i was going to say that from each other
i was going to say that myself yeah
clearly didn't happen
but my husband i'd let you say it i was
gonna let you say it because you're the
guest
thank you i appreciate it but when i
first got it my husband and i stood here
and looked at it for like 30 minutes and
talked about all the different pieces
and i just love it it's my favorite
thing i bought during the pandemic wow
that is a nerdy marriage
i know
you're not that wrong that's what's so
sad about it it's like it's so fun i
love it isn't it beautiful
it's beautiful it's beautiful in a geeky
sort of way it's beautiful
yeah yeah well if you got your own
following you know geek following you
gotta be card carrying geek all the way
that's it so
i'm all in yep yeah so so chuck you've
got you collected questions from our
patreon members because this is a cosmic
queries that's right and and kate i'll
be coming back to you about your
periodic table and you know
intermittently because i me and periodic
table go way back too i got neil's
another lover of the periodic table oh
don't don't get me started on the
periodic table but okay what i want to
do i want to try to because i know the
periodic table from the
through the lens of an astrophysicist
so and and and kate you clearly are
chemist with your periodic table i'm
going to come at you with some astro
chemistry
see
just to see
just to see see if you can hang with the
astro chemist all right
we're gonna try that a little later
we're gonna have to go into the octagon
for this one oh my god two nerds enter
and they both leave but one of them with
a little more respect
it's nerd thunderdome
[Laughter]
i would watch that yeah yeah me too me
too all right so what do you got chuck
all right let's just jump into it who we
got here we have oh i i like this the
artist formerly known as james smith
hello dr tyson dr bieberdorf and chuck
chuck if you mess up my name you should
just give it up buddy
bro
i really got to read these beforehand
here's my question where do we find
lithium on earth and how can we find
more of it does it exist on other
planets i love you guys have a great day
let me give a hand off to kate on this
it's the it's the
it is
made in tiny quantities in the big bang
very tiny quantities but it is made
unlike most other elements that have to
wait for billions of years for stars to
create them in their cores the big bang
itself makes a little bit of lithium now
let me hand that over to kate so it's og
it's a it's an old original gangster
little even here from the beginning
don't kill the comeback kate we need to
column the og elements we need that
element i love it i love it oh that's
really funny i'm gonna have to pitch
that we'll see what people say of that
one um lithium is like all the most of
the other metals we find it in oxide
form a lot of times in mines um i
believe lithium was discovered back in
the 1800s in sweden and it was formed
with an eliminate aluminum silicate as
well so there's a little bit of aluminum
there and a little bit of silicon mixed
in so it's in the mines just like all
our other metals to find it deep in the
crust of the earth so you're saying it's
not it doesn't come in its own
um veins through the crust it's it's
mixed in with other elements
most of them are not i know that we do
have it in oxide forms i don't know if
we can find it by itself but it's very
possible but are the forms i know that
are in the oxide form so there's an
oxygen attached to it somehow which is
making it stable because otherwise it'd
be extraordinarily reactive so before we
uh move on let me ask you guys both this
so if iron is our core
do we find the core of earth yes
sorry if that's our core do we find
different elements at different levels
or is it just kind of all mixed in and
then you know
how how does it work in terms of like as
you get down to like the iron do you
find different things at different
levels as you go down
chuck the heavy stuff is in the middle
and the light stuff floated that's
that's all it's not that complicated is
that it
is seriously that easy is it really that
easy well wait so chuck chuck wait just
to be clear we think of rocks as heavy
because they like sink in the water but
the water is floating on the rocks and
the rocks are floating on everything
else that is heavier than they are that
went to the center of the earth so rocks
are light by comparison yeah gotcha so
here's a question kate how do you get if
why didn't all the iron go to the middle
of the earth how can we have these oars
of iron that come up into the crust yeah
well it has to do with attractions right
every single one of these atoms have
protons in the center and electrons on
the outside and it just has to do with
what it interacted with on its way down
to the center oh it's a lot of the
oxygen it's going to have a reaction
with that we all know rust happens so
readily here right right these are going
to rust out at certain points before
exactly yeah um so just it's what it
interacted with that's what chemistry is
all the time what is in its environment
what's its system what's its
surroundings what's going on around so
when we find these ore deposits they're
just distracted iron basically
they were on their way they were on
their way and just like what's that
what's that over there what's that
what's that oxygen atom check out
hey oxygen what's it up
too late
bam oh damn it i missed it
the midnight train of georgia just left
all right dwight we gotta take a quick
break when we come back uh we'll pick up
our cosmic queries with kate the chemist
on star talk
we're back star talk cosmic queries with
kate the chemist we're talking about
chemistry something we don't do often
enough chuck i think yes this is you
know we do so many other things and
we've got to give some chemistry it's
due
and so we got kate kate a professor
chemistry
associate professor of chemistry yeah
yeah of instruction yeah yeah yeah at
the university of texas at austin and uh
we're delighted to have you you're kate
the chemist and what are your your
social media handles
i am at kate the chemist on instagram
and tick tock i just hit a hundred
thousand followers on tic pack which i'm
so excited about
um which i know is not a lot for you
guys but for me that makes me very happy
no 100 000 excuse me
there's a lot for anybody that's for
anybody
i just made a mental mental note i gotta
get on top
guys please get on tic tac it's so fun i
really enjoy it it's a very easy way to
communicate science with other people
and just give them little snippets and
i'm really enjoying i never thought i'd
say that ever but i'm really enjoying it
yeah very cool cool
all right so uh chuck what do you got
for us all right let's just jump these
are still patreon members right all
patreon yeah all patreons don't change
the rule they're the only ones who get
to ask questions if you are interested
in asking us a question patreon is the
way you have to do it it was a way for
us to kind of democratize actually um
actually just the opposite of that it's
the opposite just the opposite of
democratize i'm sorry it was a way for
us to cull
the uh the pool
it's not to democratize to monetize
that's the word all right exactly all
right go for it chuck here we go this is
max madison he says hey dr bieberdorf
why do you think many scholars including
isaac newton believed in or practiced
alchemy even as recently as the 1900s do
you think it was for greed or was it
truly for the pure pursuit of science
yeah
plus kate i would add to that from the
alchemy i've read there seemed to be
some mysticism in there as well at least
if you go far back so how does all that
square working its way so deep into the
industrial revolution for example
well it's really funny because from a
chemist point of view when we think of
alchemy it's just more of the study of
chemistry before we knew it was going on
and it was just people mixing things
together and trying to kind of cook here
and there and sometimes they came up
with medicines that were helpful and
sometimes they came up with crap that
was not helpful at all um and so it just
depends on kind of where you fall and so
for me when i think of it it just is
like the chemistry before you know the
1900s before we had any clue what was
going on
so is it now with that is eye of newt on
the periodic
yes here it is
[Laughter]
have you see i saw this comic once it
was um
vegetarian witches right and so it was
eye of
potato head of lettuce
yeah it was
yeah so that's a really good answer i
like that so what you're saying is
it's the best people could do before
they really knew what was going on but
then but why is it such an insult though
you know what you say oh you're just an
alchemist and it's like people will
fight you if you call them that but
you're saying it should not carry a
stigma
i don't think of it yeah yeah exactly
like i don't honestly think of it with a
stigma i think of it as people doing the
best they could with what they had i
mean this was pre-internet this was
before we were sharing information so
easily you know this is just what they
had that they had available to them
okay i don't think anything negative
i don't want to have to school you in
this way but okay we are post-internet
and there are people who think earth is
flat so don't think the internet fixes
stuff okay
just no that's not what i meant that
sound that is exactly what you meant
no no it's not it's a way of people to
communicate for scientists to tell each
other and share information more readily
and that's all i mean by it and so
before we had that you have an elitist
internet you have to go well you'd have
to go to the library and you'd have to
read a book and you'd have to find that
very specific book and so it's easier to
find that information in the internet
that's all i'm saying but yeah okay
see she's on the internet for smart
people okay
for everybody else we got flat earthers
we are on the d.a.i
the dumbass internet that's what we are
on
the d.a.i all right
all right what else you got chuck give
it to me here we go um
uh this is elias
uh
siametis i think okay how you spelling
uh
s-i-a-m-e-t-i-s
so either cyanide is or c a medicine
sheer matters all right i'll give you
you know you've got a 50 chance 50
seconds right and elias if i messed up
your name change it anyway um
[Laughter]
all right here we go hello dr tyson dr
bieberdorf and lord chuck oh man look at
you what are some fun chemistry
experiments that i can do at home for my
twins other than the ones in your books
because we have done those at what age
do you think it is appropriate or
beneficial to get them started
oh well let's start with that one
immediately as soon as they can start
talking um i think it's really important
to get that inquiry mind try to ask
questions and i think it's really
important too to announce that you don't
know everything and it's okay not to
know everything as a scientist that's
what we're doing is exploring we have we
have questions and then we're searching
for answers and so if you can kind of
break down science into that right at
the young age then kids love science
it's all fun about explosions and
exploration um what i would highly
recommend is try elephant toothpaste
that's that's not well it didn't the
kid's version is in my book but do the
big kid version um grab 35 hydrogen
peroxide from a medical supply store or
order potassium iodide off of amazon
don't use yeast because yeast isn't
going to do anything but use order
potassium iodide use dish soap make sure
it's not natural dish soap natural dish
soap doesn't have high surfactant in it
so it doesn't bubble as much and so like
dawn dish soap is fantastic add some
food coloring use a big flask and
erlenmeyer flask is best and add it
right together add potassium glass it's
going to shoot out the top as the
hydrogen peroxide decomposes i mean
everybody loves that everybody loves
that that's they love that kids love it
you know outside outside it'll destroy
your ceiling doesn't it make a big mess
yeah yes
there's tarps and there's also things
like you can wash stuff outside no big
deal
did you see the internet video where
they did a
um a version of that where it is almost
half a city block that they filled with
that
yeah
it's insane they made a set it's like
half a city block
as as a square a half a city block
square
and they just did it they built the
whole thing
it's insane it's insane it is
it made me so nervous because they did
one right before that where i don't
think their safety was up personally
like it got too close to them i don't
think they were anything it made me so
nervous that they were going to get just
covered in this stuff which is just not
good for your skin yeah that i saw that
one too and they're running away from it
in that video
and i'm like
yes i'm like you people are insane
yeah okay yeah but i'm glad they did it
it was a cool video no one got hurt so
that's all i care about but kate does
does that
mixture
have
any utility at all other than the
demonstration of a geyser
well to be honest i use it in my
classroom to to talk about either
stoichiometry or catalysis and so you
can talk about how you can use another
molecule to come in and break apart a
certain molecule into new pieces because
what happens is hydrogen peroxide
decomposes into oxygen gas and water and
it's extremely exothermic so it's really
hot so your students can actually feel
the heat so you can talk about it in
thermodynamics
yeah okay so it's very it's very uh
educationally helpful right yeah it's
very educated constructive yeah yeah
yeah i'm i'm going to say i i just want
to stop you because i don't care if i
don't know something that's why i love
doing this stoic stoichiometry and
catalysis you sounded like you just told
me i was going to die
i'm sorry chuck because you have
stoichiometry and ketosis
oh no you have six months to live so i
don't know what those are i don't know
what those no our stoichiometry tells us
that you have the catalysis
stoichiometry is just the chemistry
version of dimensional analysis so if
you're saying like i'm going 60 miles an
hour and i have 100 miles to go how long
is it going to take me to get there
that's dimensional analysis so it's just
basic unit conversion stoichiometry is
you throw molecules on top of it so you
got a little carbon dioxide you got some
methane and you just go through the math
and so you can do that with the
decomposition and go through how much
oxygen you would expect to produce and
it's a very fun i say fun exercise
because then you use the explosion and
catalysis you've probably heard of the
catalyst before and so that's where you
just have a new molecule and it takes
two other molecules and brings them
together and so it's essentially a um
it's like it's like the highway for a
reaction instead of the back roads so
when you throw in a catalyst it allows
it to go way fast and it's on a much
faster route and it's just better
usually
otherwise it's a bad catalyst awesome
that's great thank you all right good
good all right all right what's next
chuck here we go this is roman precup uh
who says hey hey dr tyson and did they
ever say where they're from i always
like knowing where they're from no they
didn't they don't say okay yeah i mean
guys if you want to start um including
that for neil that would be great i will
definitely uh include it in your
question um roman prick up says uh hey
dr tyson dr bieber lord nice what is
stopping us from using h
instead of l i
n l ion batteries which i believe would
be a lithium-ion battery right uh
theoretically they should be able to
form the same connections with other
elements and h is lighter than li so
hydrogen and lithium is it only because
h is the only s one non-metal element uh
you know what i was understanding
everything he said right up until that
point
now you're just showing off roman i
don't wait
i gotta i gotta slip in here get a
little astrophysics so
you may remember on your periodic table
hydrogen is listed twice right uh sort
of as a gas and as a as a metal oh we
have a live demonstration of it there so
under very high pressures hydrogen takes
on the properties of metals and in the
center of jupiter which is 90 hydrogen
the hydrogen manifests as metal and it
conducts electricity and it does all the
things metals do and and jupiter has the
ferocious magnetic field as a result of
it but everywhere else hydrogen is just
like regular hydrogen so kate over to
you
so it's a gas so the main difference is
of the gas and so lithium is going to be
a metal we can force it to be in the
aqueous state so we can dissolve it in
water but hydrogen the gas and so that
immediately changes everything about how
it would operate
one thing we always talk about is how we
could eventually try to replace a gas
tank in a car with hydrogen gas and so
when i say gas tank i'm actually talking
about the liquid that you pump into your
tank whereas hydrogen gasoline gasoline
yeah thank you thank you that's what i'm
trying to say
whereas hydrogen gas is an actual
explosive gas and it would be really
really dangerous to put that on our car
if we got into an accident because that
would be a huge explosion like that's
unbelievably flammable and you can store
it under pressure it's super dangerous
if it gets knocked into um so that's one
of the biggest hiccups is that it's a
gas and it's flammable so it's very
dangerous and we have to take care of it
all lithium slammable as well so there's
pieces that was about to say oh yeah the
lithium portion of the flames too
doesn't it
i was like yeah
i got a feeling lithium might be in the
same category since they're telling me
to take my battery out of my suitcase
when i'm flying
okay so maybe it's just not as flammable
like an explosive is that a fair uh
characterization that's fair
and it's stored under pressure like you
said that pressure component really
changes things
right all right so then but just to be
clear and that s one little ditty he put
at the end there thank you uh if i
understand that correctly okay correct
me if i'm wrong that uh lithium appears
directly beneath hydrogen on the
periodic table and that and everybody in
a column
in principle can make the same families
of molecules and this is what all he was
saying there right kate
yes that's exactly right so both
hydrogen and lithium have one electron
in their very first shell that little
that external valence spot so in the 1s
shell hydrogen as one in the 2s shell
hydrogen or lithium is one
yeah okay right we got one well i gotta
say
chemistry is a lot of fun i'm right it
is
when kate is teaching it
yeah
i was ready to jump through the webcam
and hug you like it breaks
when i hear that chemistry teachers are
awful i hear it all the time
kate you're not helping me here
yeah no
no chuck did need a hug in that moment
that this is true you needed a hug
clearly i did because i didn't even
realize i was harboring all that until
that point
all right let's go to jim kelly and jim
kelly says hi dr bieberdorf when i took
chemistry in college it was the late 80s
i had a lab partner who told me the
story of when the chemistry in high
school he mixed some things together
that caused a cloud of gas to billow
forth my vague memory was that it was
green
when the teacher saw it he yelled to the
class to evacuate immediately luckily no
one was hurt i don't remember what he
said the cloud of glass he created was
but i'm curious you have any idea what
chemicals would be available in a high
school chemistry class that could cause
this kind of event and what indeed was
produced hey chuck
you pronounce my name
jim
man
you know what jim people don't have any
confidence in you no i know that was
wrong jim that was wrong
jim chuck was having a hard day today i
know and look what he did to you
so so kate you know any magic green gas
cloud recipes chlorine i'm sure it's
chlorine gas is what the teacher was
afraid they made um so chlorine gas is
yellow green it's not good to breathe in
it can go into your lungs it dissolves
in the water vapor that's in your lungs
and so it forms hydrochloric acid so
then you have acid in your lungs that
can be burning up from the ends oh
there's stuff that can happen yeah it
burns it's terrible it's absolutely mean
so wait so kate wait so kate if chlorine
is a gas
and
but of course when mixed with sodium
it's just salt
why would why do we fear hydrogen in a
battery
if if it's gas but then if it mixes
together with something else it's no
longer a gas
well it depends on what the phase would
be right and what what its
comical compound would actually be just
like you're saying because if it's
something with hydrogen partnered with
another
metal it could be something that could
be right quite reactive so in lab we use
something called lithium aluminum
hydride and so when the hydrogen
actually has that electron instead of
giving it up and forming an acid or a
proton instead of when it has that
electron it can actually be quite
reactive and it's very dangerous so when
we use lithium aluminum hydride in lab
you end up having to take your flask and
put it in a liquid nitrogen fat so you
soak it in something that's at 77 kelvin
or negative 194 celsius because it's so
reactive so that my gut instinct is i
don't want a battery with that
okay i don't want to be anywhere near
that all right but but a little known
fact that the the orange fuel tank
that was the main tank of the space
shuttle orbiter when it launched it had
the two solid rocket boosters on the
side and then the main tank in the
middle
was it had two tanks inside of it and
one of those two tanks is twice the size
of the other
precisely twice the size and the one
that's twice as big had liquid hydrogen
in it and the one that was half the size
had liquid oxygen in it and you blend
them together they pick up a two to one
ratio and out comes the exhaust which is
just water and so the so so you're
saying we can't do that in a car
i don't think so not safely um have you
ever been around those doers
the doers are they're the vacuum sealed
containers that are you have to in order
to keep something in the liquid phase so
in order to have nitrogen if you've ever
seen liquid nitrogen it's kept in these
dewars they're vacuum sealed containers
because nitrogen wants to be in a gas in
our environment here on earth same thing
with hydrogen it wants to be a gas you'd
have to use a special container which
are ridiculously heavy um so on top of
the fact that things are pressurized i i
just realized it's happening in the near
future i asked you a stupid question
because of course those tanks they're
kept refrigerated until launch right so
yeah you can't do that with it there's
that piece not in texas
yeah you guys don't even have
electricity
blood drawn
all right we got to take another quick
break uh we come back more with kate the
chemist as we loving it because chuck
has learned some chemistry for the first
time in his life and so
all right we'll be back in a moment on
star talk
we're back star talk cosmic queries
edition all about chemistry
it's our first foray with a pure
chemistry
uh
episode here and i'm loving it and we
got kate the chemist anybody that's
named kate the chemist you got to have
him on the show see because he's
no one voluntarily just randomly calls
himself the chemist unless they can like
mix some stuff together and uh and and
kate you met your your husband in your
chemistry department correct i did yeah
we were both getting phds in inorganic
chemistry we met in welch hall uh he was
behind me in our saturday morning
seminars and like making jokes about
things and it made me laugh and just we
fell in love
wow but now now he's in uh software
engineering correct yeah software
engineering he's coding um he's quite an
introvert and i'm quite an extrovert so
it's pretty good balance so yeah so
chuck so if you have a couple where they
both are completely chemically fluent
right you got they have to really stay
in love their whole time because
that could get really good
yeah you're not lying here honey drink
this exactly
yeah that's a that's a terrible
yeah you don't want to make your your
wife mad when she knows how to put
together concoctions that will burn you
up from the inside on the inside this is
this is this is nine episodes of csi
ready to be written right here
okay
i'd have to be very careful about it
that's for sure
and and kate i think you only mentioned
two platforms when i last asked tik tok
and uh was it twitter or instagram yeah
facebook instagram and tick tock i'm at
kate the chemist on twitter i'm k with
the number eight the chemist someone
else stole my handle there so ouch
all right i got we got people we can
take care of that
thank you chuck call our people i will
without
yeah you'll have it in the morning okay
thank you
thank you so much
all right chuck give me some more here
we go this is sparrow chaos
sparrow chaos says hello astrophysicist
neil tyson and chemist kate bieberdorf
and chuck
um
how does dissolving a salt molecule in
water
make its atoms
ionize
oh
yeah are you ready for this okay it's
actually pretty simple um so what they
do is they form what are referred to as
ion dipole interactions and so the salt
goes in and it's a it's in a lattice so
when you think of sodium chloride i'm
sure you don't
you don't think of it in this big like
cage but that's what it looks like so
there's a sodium ion then a chloride ion
and then a sodium and chloride and
sodium chloride and they alternated
it's a huge box exactly a big cube
so the sodium atom is boxed in
by the chlorine atoms
they're all actually they're completely
surrounded and yeah exactly okay
interesting like a cube every other
corner is a sodium and then every other
corner is a chloride and so they just
rotate because it's a one-to-one ratio
so they're already technically in the
ion form when they're in salt because
it's a sodium ion attracted to a
chloride ion and that's what forms the
sodium chloride so they're already
together and so when that cube drops
into the water they form the ion dipole
interaction so the ions from the salt
dipoles from the water because water is
shaped in this beautiful little point
kind of if you will so the oxygen's at
the top and then the hydrogens are
directly below it and so you this is
this forms an interaction with the salt
and they come together it's called an
ion dipole interaction and salt water i
have to show off it's 105 degree angle
is that correct
it might be um i know it's less than
109.5 degrees because it's in the bent
form um oh okay that's all i knew i just
wanted i just had to show off that
little bit of thing that's all i knew
okay as far as i'm concerned you're
talking about fm radio stations right i
know 109.5 okay
classic rock all the time 109.5
the ion station
coming to you live right now
so it's it's just lives that way that is
the natural state yeah they break they
break apart and so the ions then kind of
separate by themselves you have a sodium
ion that's completely surrounded by
water and so since sodium is positive
it's going to be attracted to the oxygen
negative side of water so that the o's
are going to be surrounded by michigan
just came out my o's are going to be
around
and then the chloride the chlorine on
the other side is negative and so that's
going to be surrounded by the hydrogen
component of the water molecule so it's
completely gonna arrange so all the ions
separate out and they're completely
surrounded by tons and tons of water
molecules and that's what your salt
water actually is
beautiful okay so the whole ocean is
this is what you're saying yeah well
plus a lot of other crap there's plastic
in there there's coral reefs there's
plastic
and fish fish poop fish poop yeah yeah
carbon dioxide these days so yeah
okay yeah yeah i know
sorry to go
all right yeah she had to bum us out all
right okay all right so chuck what else
you have all right so let's uh let's go
from a brine to a food question this is
uh
this is
that's chuck's only chemistry works my
only chemistry
that i can do
you're talking about so okay forget it
uh carrie manaberg says this uh hi dr
kate and dr tyson this is a food
chemistry question is it true cooking
vegetables will reduce their nutritional
value and denature some enzymes some raw
veggies taste great but when you roast a
veggie like onions or carrots they taste
even better tastes so much better
so kate what happens when some heat
slaps on to some some big vegetable
molecules or vitamins vitamins i guess
is the nutritional part of this yeah
well so the molecules for vitamins are
either going to be fat soluble or water
soluble so it depends on how you're
cooking them so if you have a lot of oil
in there then the vitamins will dissolve
in your oil or your fat and so that will
be pulled out and depending on if you
eat that liquid that's around there it's
very possible that it will dissolve out
of there wow
okay so if you knew in advance whether
it's water soluble or or
or oil soluble you might cook your
vegetables differently to avoid that
perhaps but in general the idea is just
to minimize the amount of oil you don't
want that stuff in your body anyway you
don't want any of those fats you want to
minimize it because it's not good for
your arteries okay but i bet what he'd
talk about when you roast onions you're
not you're putting them neither in oil
nor water you're just slapping those
puppies on the grill right next to your
t-bone right so how about if it's just
pure heat and you get those little brown
marks on your
on your caramel onions yeah the
caramelization exactly
some of that yeah
and so caramelization is when you have
your sugars and so that can be either
your complex carbohydrates smarter
starches or those could be your simple
sugars which are actually sugars and so
when you go through caramelization
you're breaking down the sugars you're
making them into smaller molecules um so
you are changing their chemical
composition but i i don't think
necessarily that's making it better or
worse for you for onions specifically
i'm more for me i'm more worried about
cooking your veggies and a lot of oil or
fat but sure surely there's some
molecules that don't like the heat and
it'll just bust them and
break them apart
that's that's different though that's
talking about if you had too much heat
so if you had too much heat then your
molecules are going to completely
decompose like actually break apart
instead of breaking into smaller
molecules so it's like whether or not
it's like breaking into more of its
elemental states or whether or not it's
breaking into smaller molecules that are
still tasty and aromatic and give things
the smell still of themselves okay
interesting yeah so that's is that the
difference between
decomposing and biodegrading
well that depends too so biodegrading is
going to be something that usually
happens outside right so you have like
your um what am i trying to think of so
like six pack rings um those need to be
biodegradable and so that's when
sunlight hits it so high energy uv
radiation will hit it um and do trigger
some kind of chemical reactions as well
but those are usually photosensitive
chemicals okay okay
all right all right just checking that
out
all right
good
speaking of water soluble uh who who
knew who would it who would have known
that the wicked witch of the west was
water-soluble
you know that's
that's just an interesting little fact
we need some chemists to work on that i
think i think they got to get to get
some top people trying to figure that
one out what kind of life form is she
where that occurs right right
all right chuck keep in coming all right
here we go this is uh
brady
fighter and brady fighter says hello all
from los alamos california nice my
question is in the world of chemistry is
there ever any thought to the
possibility that new chemistry might
someday be discovered in the way that
the physical world is grappling with the
ideas of dark matter or dark energy or
in the same realm of possibilities uh
like a chemical world that sort of
exists maybe in the quantum realm wait
so chuck we this is a this is a a movie
trailer ready to happen
in a world
in a world yeah i love that question so
so kate are we living in the entire one
and only chemistry universe that i
refuse to yeah
go can you imagine a whole other
chemical realm
that is apart and distinct from
everything we're doing now
yes and i think it would be ignorant to
say that we know everything now for
chemistry i mean we can't figure out how
the electron moves across or newton from
the nucleus like it it teleports from
one side of the atoms the other we can't
figure that out so to claim that we know
exactly what's going on it's just
gibberish but i do think we know a lot
more than we did a hundred years ago so
we've made a lot of progress i really
wish i was gonna be alive like two or
three hundred years from now because i
think that's when the chemistry is gonna
be just like ah beautiful
wow that wow that that's like a chef
does it yeah it's kind of kiss your
fingers and pop up your hands we're back
to cooking with chemistry
but but but wait a minute so in physics
there are entire branches of physics
that were discovered right so relativity
was a branch of physics and quantum
physics a branch of physics uh so
is there a branch of chemistry you can
imagine waiting to be discovered
oh man that is such a good question
i'm just extending the question
from our guy yeah
yeah i honestly i can't put a name to it
but a hundred percent because i think i
just think we don't know everything
right now i think there's so much more
to figure out we have a decent
understanding the atom but we still
can't see it our microscopes are getting
better and better and better but we're
just it's not perfect yet and so i think
we're so close to learning a lot like
we're right on the cost so hopefully
okay so right now we're playing with
atoms but and they're doing stuff we
just accept but we haven't gotten in it
to say hey
i saw you do that and now i understand
it we just kind of
we agree with each other this is what it
does and we make stuff out of it and
move on
yeah we haven't found an experiment to
break down our theories yet but i think
it's coming okay wow
okay yeah hopeful very hopeful okay here
we go this is
uh
kevin ho
kevin says hello dr tyson and dr
bieberdorf when we hear the word chemist
we often think of some mad scientists
working in an underground lab with lots
of different beakers and flasks boiling
away do either of you know any mad or
maybe just kind of crazy scientist in
your field
kate other than yourself is there any
you you need not implicate yourself in
this question you have immunity
diplomatic immunity here so yeah it's is
it possible to know a lot of chemistry
and be diabolical so that you end up
doing things uh
nefarious
for sure 100
um we've heard some really sad stories
about people who've taken their own
lives because they know enough and they
do it in kind of horrendous ways so i
don't like that i don't like that side
but i do think that chemists in general
are quite fun we usually use our skills
for good uh so a lot of us you'll find
usually it's an element
okay but we're you know we're out there
trying to promote science make
scientists look good i want to show that
anybody can be a scientist it doesn't
matter who you are what you look like
but honestly anybody can be a scientist
if you have a question technically you
are a scientist so
okay
okay and can you be a scientist if
you're not simultaneously wearing a lab
coat that's the yes that's the question
hey you're in the kitchen if you're in
the kitchen you're cooking so you do it
every night cooking is chemistry if
there's anything if it's anything it's
chemistry chemistry and thermodynamics
as well yes
allow me to add that slip that one in
there yeah i'll take it
all right chuck let's go into a fast
lightning round so okay you have to
answer in fewer than five words what
your questions are give it to me okay
all right here we go
uh this is uh gerald johnson gerald
johnson from seattle he says i have
reese's specific a scientific plateau
has
have we reached a scientific plateau or
has science discovery invention just
slowed down compared to the days of old
kind of what you were just talking about
yeah yeah so yes or no king no we
haven't reached the end of that we just
got vaccines no okay
she's like i just got a booster shot
what's your problem
okay it's possible that i mean a lot of
advances happen on the frontiers of
journals and doesn't always make it into
the newspapers and then and then there
are kate what are they called who bring
chemistry into popular products that uh
just
engineering chemists you know chemical
engineers right who then do interesting
things with it so yeah
yeah i mean i yeah i i have to disagree
with the person as well i'm on kate's
side with this okay keep going all right
we took more than five words to do it
yes
friedrich johansson says this uh hello
doctors and lords
chucky don't get too accustomed to that
joke you know what i gotta tell you at
first i was like oh god i can't believe
this is still but now i'm kind of like i
like the sound of it anyway
team seas is the initiative to get funds
to remove plastic from the oceans is
there some plausible chemistry uh as a
means of removing plastic and more
importantly micro plastic from our seas
yeah so kate you got like a microbe
that would have to include biochemistry
right some microbes that would munch on
plastic
and either you know return it to then
base ingredients and die return it to an
or or you know chuck it'll eat the
plastic and then it'll become super
microbes
right yeah that would be careful what we
wish for here right so so kate what's
the future of chemists helping the
oceans
i'll give you more than five words
because we're gonna end on this question
i'm gonna give you more than five words
go i would i would say i agree with your
answer on that the only thing i'd be
concerned of is any waste that would
then be produced in that reaction so if
they're producing methane or producing
something else that could be bad for our
environment i do think moths could be
the answer so metal organic frameworks
so they're like those cages we discussed
before so they would essentially trap
the plastic if you will and then you'd
be able to kind of filter that whole
thing out in general so that might be a
future but the long way for that one wow
so this is a
it's an incarceration system where you
yeah i don't like the sound of that yeah
i don't know about that you know what's
gonna happen now all the black plastic
is all locked up
the white plastic still roaming the
ocean just as free as they ever was
that means it's time to end the show
because chuck we can never reel chuck
back when he goes on that way
kate it's been a delight to have you we
know we're going to want you back
and my one little sort of i have more
but i would throw out a chem a
periodic table tidbit so we
astrophysicists discovered an element on
the sun
before we discovered it here on earth
do you know which element that is
oh god it's either gonna be hydrogen and
helium
helium yep you got it uh so helios so we
named it after the greek sun god helios
and so that was
the a rare case where we had better data
from the universe than we did than we
can produce here on earth so oh yeah
and so uh so that's my one little tri
and i can say i helped
it's okay we're all gonna look for your
book so that finally adults can blow
stuff up the way you did as kids tell me
the name of the book again and where can
we find it
it's elemental the hidden chemistry of
everything and it's sold anywhere books
are sold
anywhere books are sold that's the
answer now yeah that's how that goes all
right well thanks for being a cherished
guest on star talk and i assure you this
will this is your first and it won't be
your last provided you agree provided
you survived chuck i'll be back
you think you'll think you'll be back
all right chuck always good to have you
as my co-host here all right i'm neil
degrass tyson your personal
astrophysicist as always keep looking up
[Music]